today we're going to play two truths in
a lie regarding near-death experiences I
was in a surfing accident when I was
nine you fall off the board presumably
the wave just kind of took me under I
spun around a little bit and then I just
smashed my my arm on a on a rock while I
was cycling uh a car plowed through me
what did your girlfriend do is she
freaking out and then she comes and see
that I'm unconscious and my pillow is
soaked in blood your pillow was soaked
in blood in the ER yeah so my head was
took it out I was in a deadly car
accident when I was a teenager the car
ended up on its side but all I really
remember was like being thrown around
and like this really horrible crunching
sound but you're leaning towards Tony
I'm leaning towards Tony you definitely
drilled into him the most I think Tony's
a prime suspect Tony you're a liar
[Music]
I was lying